Okay, so first we'll begin with determinate.
The permanent this should be okay determinant.
A matrix now, of course, we can only calculate determinant
office of matrices that are square.
So consider the following example, this is very straightforward and we have
a matrix.
the determinant of a matrix
is denoted by the ET to compute
the
determinant of a
square Matrix is to
take the product.
of the components across
the diagonal
this is only true for the square major for our two by two. I'll show you how it's
not worth 2 by 3.
Take the product of a a sub 1
1 and a sub 2 2 so across this diagonal.
Then take the product of the opposite diagonal
or the opposite direction and then sum
them.
so determinant of a 2 by 2 Matrix is
for a 3 by 3 or yeah for
a three by three or larger.
let me
let me let me show you how it's done.
I'm going to so this is for us. This is for
our two by two four.
two by two Matrix
for three by three
Okay, so let's add one more Row one more column.
now
to calculate this
maybe augment this let me copy paste the
same Matrix. So becomes e visually easier to
See, I'm gonna copy that bit.
And I'm going to copy it once more.
And let me actually put them next to each other.
Okay, let's put some line break.
in order to calculate the determinant of
the three by three
we're going to multiply.
again
everything across the diagonal so this times this
times this
so the third column of the third row.
But then we also have to multiply these components.
And those components so on the upper triangle the lower triangle. How
do we do this?
Well, the reason I augmented this Matrix is because we want to
multiply three components three components three components.
So after Computing the elements
across the main diagonal then we're going
to multiply a12.
times a23
and then a31
So this element?
Will come all the way up here.
Maybe it's and let me also just show you this from a different angle. So
I'm going to type in determinant.
of a 3 by 3 Matrix
and let's use yeah, here we go.
So this is this this is a three by three which has been
argumented.
Okay.
So we multiply the products across the main diagonal.
And then we have B sub 1 C sub 2.
Which we wanted me to multiply with a sub 3. So we're
going to copy a sub three all the way here. I mean that's all point of
mirroring.
Or reflecting if you want this Matrix so
we can have this.
business this diagonal business
And then of once we've done it from there, once we've done
across the main dial will go the other direction. So C sub 1
B sub 2 a sub 3
and then a sub 1 is up to so
basically exactly what I just said.
Okay.
These elements these elements and these elements. So you
see when we when we copy The Matrix.
Now in the examples I showed you an example you will see they will
leave the spit out.
But I think it's just more clear if I make a duplicate.
Okay, so let's look at an example.
Just two by two.
And then we'll move on to the next topic.
So let's say
we have
the square Matrix. I'm going to copy paste.
code
and let's say we have
You know, whatever this will be for.
This will be three.
This will be eight.
and let's make this 2
so 2 times 3 minus 8 times 2
Now what will this evaluate to there? So that will be six minus 16.
so negative 10
That's the determinant of this Matrix.
Now we leave this here and come back to it.
To well, of course for every concept that
we see here. We want to know what's what's
A practically example of using the determined. So let's keep
this year so we can refer to later on.